الى الضفه الغربيه حيث استشهد شاب فلسطيني
امريكي برصاص قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
شرق مدينه رام الله وقال والد الشهيد ان
قوات الاحتلال لاحقت المركبه التي كان
يقودها ابنه الشهيد في منطقه عيون الحرميه
التي شهدت مواجهات مع قوات الاحتلال وبذلك
يرتفع عدد الشهداء الفلسطينيين في الضفه
الغربيه الى
369 منذ بدايه الحرب على غزه من بينهم 50
شهيدا منذ بدايه العام
الحالي كما افاد الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني
باصابه شاب فلسطيني برصاص الاحتلال خلال
اقتحام قوات الاحتلال مدينه نابلس شمال
الضفه الغربيه وقد سيرت قوات الاحتلال
دورياتها في شارع رفيديا وسط المدينه حيث
اندلعت مواجهات بين او مع شبان فلسطينيين
ادت الى اصابه شاب برصاصه في القدم وتوجهت
الدوريات الاسرائيليه بعدها الى غرب مدينه
نابلس قبل انسحابها
منها وفي جنين اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي حي خروبه شمالي المدينه ودهمت
منزل الشهيد رافت ابو عقل واعتدت على
عائلته كما اعتقلت شقيقه وعبثت بمحتويات
المنزل قبل ان
تنسحب كما اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الليله الماضيه مخيم شعفاط
شمال القدس المحتله واعتقلت سيده فلسطينيه
وسيرت يات راجله واليه وانتشرت في عدد من
الاحياء كما اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال بلده
الخضر في مدينه بيت لحم واطراف مخيم
الدهيشه قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه اقتحمت
ايضا الليله الماضيه مدينه بيت لحم وسيرت
دوريات عند ساحه المهد وسط المدينه كما
اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بلده بني
نعيم شرقي مدينه الخليل جنوب الضفه
الغربيه
معنا من نابلس مراسل الجزيره ليث جعار ليث
اخر التطورات المرتبطه بالاقتحام
الاسرائيليه في عموم الضفه
الغربيه نعم تتواصل عمليات الاحتلال
العسكريه في الضفه الغربيه المحتله والتي
تزايدت خلال الايام والاشهر السابقه حيث
باتت الضفه الغربيه على صفيح ساخن من خلال
او بسبب الاقتحامات المتواصله لاحياء
متفرقه وبلدات ومخيمات في الضفه الغربيه
المحتله منذ ساعات الليل قوات الاحتلال
تنفذ حمله مداهمات واسعه لمناطق الضفه
الغربيه المحتله حيث هنا في مدينه النابلس
كان هناك اقتحام ل حي رفيديا غرب المدينه
قام باعمال التكسير والتخريب لاحد المحال
التجاريه قبل ان تن سحب بشكل كامل اطلقت
النار صوب احد الشبان ما ادى الى اصابته
برصاصه في منطقه الفخذ وتم نقله الى
المستشفى بعد ذلك وخلال ساعات الليل نفذ
الاحتلال حمله اقتحام لمخيم بلاطه حيث
حاصر كافه مداخل البلده وادفع بتعزيزات
عسكريه اسرائيليه الى المنطقه حيث حاصر
المنطقه بشكل كامل و وسط الاشتباكات
المسلحه التي اندلعت حتى ساعات الصباح او
ساعات الفجر الاولى حيث انسحب الاحتلال من
المخيم نحو البوابه الغربيه او عفوا حاجز
بيت فوريك الى الشرق من المدينه ووسط
الاشتباكات المسلحه التي استمرت حتى
انسحاب جيش الاحتلال ايضا خلال ساعات
الليل كان هناك اقتحام لمدن عده كمدينه
قلقيليه ومدينه جنين ايضا مدينه بيت لحم
وايضا مدينه الخليل حيث في في قلقيليه كان
هناك اقتحام
لبلدتي عزون وايضا كفر ثلث ونفذ الاحتلال
حمله مداهمات في البلده
وايضا تمركزت الاليات العسكريه في عده
احياء من تلك البلدتين حتى انسحابها في
ساعات الصباح ايضا في مدينه بيت لحم نفذ
الاحتلال حمله مداهمه
وحصار في عده احياء وبلدات تحديدا الزاويه
او باب الزاويه ايضا باب القدس الخليل
وايضا ساحه المهد في المدينه حيث اندلعت
مواجهات على واقع هذه او هذا الاقتحام في
التزامن مع ذلك كان هناك اقتحام لمخيم عزه
وايضا مخيم الدهيشه وبلده الخضر حيث نفذ
الاحتلال حمله مداهمات واسعه طالت عددا من
الفلسطينيين بعد ذلك انسحب الاحتلال من
البلده والمخيم يمين ليرتفع حصيله
الاعتقالات منذ السابع من اكتوبر وحسب
بيان هيئه شؤون الاسرى والمحررين الى
6100 فلسطيني في الضفه الغربيه بالتزامن
مع الاقتحامات المتواصله في مدينه جنين
كان هناك اقتحام لحي الخروبه حيث داهم
الاحتلال منزل يعود لاسير محرر قام
الاحتلال بالاعتداء على ذويه واعتقال
شقيقه وانسحب الاح للال من مدينه جنين على
الفور في مدينه رام الله كان هناك في
ساعات الامس استهداف لشهيد ارتقى او
استشهد بعد اصابته برصاصه من جيش الاحتلال
في منطقه الراس في منطقه عيون الحرميه
القريبه من مسقط راس الشهيد المزرعه
الشرقيه حيث نقل الشهيد او نقلت طواقم
الهلال الاحمر الشهيد الى المستشفى ليتم
الاعلان مباشره عن استشهاده ليرتفع حصير
الشهداء منذ السابع من اكتوبر الى
36 69 شهيدا خلال اقتحامات الضفه
المتواصله والمرتفعه وهي الاعلى نسبيا
خلال الاعوام السابقه ليث جعار مراسل
الجزيره كنت معنا من نابلس شكرا
لك